a lot of you probably used Craigslist  before we know that our audience uses  Craigslist we've got a young audience  and they're always on Craigslist I  thought we'd help our audience members  make a sale or connection right now by  showing some of their craigslist ads  let's check them out first guy who  totally hates marijuana seeks a ton of  marijuana to just stare out in hatred  and definitely not smoke at all  there's this one right here sexy single  and in your 20s me too  yes of course this one looking for work  recent graduate of the Bret Michaels  fashion Academy  here we go immediate position available  in my pants space is limited  this one child care needed now kids are  in a red SUV in the Kona no audience  parking services services I recently  inherited 300 folding chairs a chainsaw  and a cow  let me cater your wedding finally air  guitarist seeks air groupies to have  lots of air sex  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]